[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode number 111
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I'm Mark Mandel.
I'm here with my
colleague, Melanie Warrick.
How are you doing
today, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: Good, Mark.
How are you?
I'm having a good morning.
MARK MANDEL: You're
having a good morning.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good
morning, good afternoon.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So this week we have
a very special person,
Sam Ramji, a VP of Product,
joining us for an interview,
basically to talk
about all things cloud.
So pretty excited about that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
He gives us a lot of oversight
in terms of just thinking
about leadership.
It's kind of zen actually.
But yes, before
we get into that,
as always, we will talk about
the cool things of the week.
And we will also end with
a question of the week.
And our question of the week is
actually, if you wanted to run
or if you're running a
Google Cloud Function,
and you wanted to run
it daily or weekly
or hourly, how would
you do this if you
don't have cron ability in
the Cloud Functions yet?
So we'll talk about that.
But let's go ahead and
talk about our cool things
of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so first
cool thing of the week
comes from some of
our favorite friends
over at CRE, customer
reliability engineering.
This week it's Will Tipton, site
reliability engineer under CRE.
They have a really
good blog post.
All the CRE ones are amazing.
You should definitely read them.
But they're talking about an
example escalation policy,
so basically how to set
up escalation policies
for your SRE teams
around what happens
when the SRE can't bring
the service back into SLO.
Either they need
help, stuff like
that-- how to set up
what they call thresholds
and how to define
them, and basically
set up these procedures and
situations so that people know
exactly what they should
be doing when and if
they need more help
above and beyond
what they can do themselves.
It's a cool read.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's good to
understand in terms of support
especially.
So another thing that we
wanted to mention for the week
is that there's a cool fine
art doppelganger feature that's
been added to the Google
Arts and Cultural app
that's out there
on iOS and Android.
And so it's kind of
a fun way to search
through existing paintings
that exist and see
what's your
doppelganger painting.
And the Google Arts
and Culture app
has actually been
around since 2016.
It's very useful in
terms of exploring
different artwork
that's out there
and exploring what's in museums.
So check it out.
MARK MANDEL: I'm
installing it right now.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
It's kind of fun.
And some of the
examples that are
already out there and showing
what people look like.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, it wouldn't be a week
of the "Google Cloud Platform
Podcast" if I didn't
talk about Kubernetes.
Many of you probably
noticed late last year
1.9 was announced as available.
It hasn't hit GKE yet,
but the blog series
that they do on a
regular basis whenever
they do a new release called
the Five Days of Kubernetes
has started for 1.9.
They've done the first,
I want to say four--
one, two, three, four.
They talk about
Windows support which
has gone beta in Kubernetes,
which is really cool;
storage; the CSI framework
which is in alpha;
a bunch of stuff around
dynamic admission controls;
client-go, so basically
the stuff if you want
to do custom controllers;
and your own sort of custom
resource definitions,
basically extend Kubernetes.
So we'll probably find,
at some point, some people
to come in and talk to us
about this kind of stuff.
If anyone on the Kubernetes
team is listening
and want to come join us,
we would love to have you.
But if not, definitely
go check out
the Five Days of Kubernetes.
They're always a good read.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
we've also got listed
in there the Kubernetes comic--
MARK MANDEL: Oh my
God, that is so good.
MELANIE WARRICK: --that
is out there that's
Smooth Sailing with Kubernetes.
It's a fun little comic
that helps give you
an understanding of this space.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
no, I love this.
If you've ever
thought to yourself,
I just don't quite get where
Kubernetes, or containers
as a whole, how that works,
or why people use them
or what's the impetus
behind that kind of stuff,
it's a really great,
light-hearted way of looking
at the ecosystem and looking
at why these things exist
and why people use them
and how they use them.
And it's just adorable.
MELANIE WARRICK: It is adorable.
And it's fun to see all
the different metaphors
that they're using throughout.
All right, well, I think
it's time to go talk to Sam.
MARK MANDEL: Let's go do that.
So today I am both
excited and delighted
to have Sam Ramji here with
us, VP of Product Management
at Google Cloud Platform.
So very happy to have you here.
How are you doing today, Sam?
SAM RAMJI: I'm doing fantastic.
Thank you, Mark, and
thank you, Melanie.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Thank you for the
wine that you brought.
That was very lovely.
SAM RAMJI: It seemed
like only good manners.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
we totally want
to talk to you today about sort
of your thoughts about tech
and cloud and open source.
But for those people who
don't know who you are--
I'm sure there aren't
very many of those--
do you want to tell
us a little about you
and your history here at Google
Cloud and what do you do?
SAM RAMJI: Oh, sure.
So I've been here for about
a total of 13 and 1/2 months.
True fact, I just
met somebody today
who's been here
13 and 1/2 years,
exactly 12 times longer than me.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow.
SAM RAMJI: And so I
have much to learn,
although I've
learned as much as I
could in the intervening time.
I've been in the
industry about 23 years.
As my family will
tell you, I'm not
good at really
anything but software.
I started programming when
I was nine in 1980 when
they put in the
Commodore PET 2001Ns
into the Oakland Unified
Public School District.
Never thought of
programming as a career,
although I kind of accidentally
was a teacher's assistant
for AP Computer Science.
I'm old enough that that
was Pascal at the time.
MELANIE WARRICK: I did Pascal.
MARK MANDEL: I
did not do Pascal.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
know about Pascal.
SAM RAMJI: Yeah, so
that's kind of me.
I'm fascinated by distributed
systems, distributed cognition.
I have a CS degree but
it's not computer science.
It's cognitive science
from UC San Diego--
also the home of Pascal,
strange coincidence.
But it's artificial
intelligence, neuroscience,
and then also things like
cognitive psychology,
linguistics.
I'm just fascinated
by how people
think, how we
think at scale, how
we think with each
other, both the success
cases and the failure cases.
And that I think is so
much of what lights me up
about cloud computing, about
large-scale digital enablement.
It's about being better and
more interesting humans together
and starting to ask
the questions, well,
what's possible now that
used to be impossible,
and how much father can we go?
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, and if you've
got this background
with cognitive science,
what do you think about what's
going on in the AI revolution
that we're having right now?
SAM RAMJI: Oh, it's fascinating.
I mean, I don't know what
the reverse of schadenfreude
is, but I graduated in 1994
into the second AI winter,
right when the promise of
AI had been way overpromised
and then it crashed.
And nobody wanted to hire us.
It was like kind of go to
the back of the hiring line.
Now we're in kind of
the third AI summer.
There's probably a
third AI winter coming.
MELANIE WARRICK: I wouldn't be
surprised if that's happening.
But I also think that
it won't completely
disappear because there's so
much that's been proven out.
But yes, it's nice to see
where it's at an upswing.
Do you wish you could go back
and do more with it again?
SAM RAMJI: You know, it's
a ridiculous privilege
to be at Google because
I'm surrounded by experts
in all of these fields.
So do it again?
Yeah, I can do that on Tuesday.
MELANIE WARRICK: True.
SAM RAMJI: Go talk to somebody
from Jeff Dean's team,
use some of our internal
tools like our new TensorFlow
automation system
and do the code lab.
Last week I took a codecation.
I took three work
days to learn Go
and to do Kubernetes
the Hard Way on GCE.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow.
SAM RAMJI: So this is a place
where you just kind of get
to keep learning.
The one thing I'll say is
really different about AI
this time is that the scope and
scale of how it gets executed,
how it's delivered, and how
it changes our experience
as humans means that we really
have to be awesome at ethics.
And that's something
that typically
deep science and ethics have
always struggled to get along--
social sciences, humanities,
and then the hard sciences,
so-called.
It would be really
helpful for us
to all start to
find ways to be more
multidisciplinary in our
team structure, more diverse
in our thinking, so that we
can start to anticipate, what's
the second, third,
fourth-order effects of these
that aren't obvious to the
person who created the tech?
So it is a major change
from '94 when I graduated.
AI just didn't have
this kind of power.
MELANIE WARRICK: I agree.
It's definitely a huge shift.
Well, so how did you
end up at Google?
SAM RAMJI: That is
a great question.
I always admired Google and
I thought these consumer
technologies that the
company built were amazing.
Obviously from search to--
I moved my entire prior
startup onto Google Docs--
Actually that was
two startups ago--
because it was just
so efficient, again,
for collaborative thinking,
how you look at what people are
thinking about in real time.
The closest thing you can
get is everybody's typing
in the same document.
It performs so well.
But I'm really a plumber.
I like distributed systems.
And I've been in distributed
systems and enterprise software
since, I don't know, 1998.
So Google never
had a place for me.
And so at that sort of
basic structural mismatch,
I never thought, oh, Google is
a company I'd want to work for.
But then a year
and a half ago when
I was the CEO of
Cloud Foundry, which
is the leading open source
platform as a service,
I started hearing
who was at Google now
and what Google cared about
and what they were doing.
And I thought, this is
becoming a place for plumbers.
We can really get really
excited about middleware.
And we can start taking
these developer platforms
and infrastructures
that Google has
built for itself that
have scaled the business,
made it the second-most
valuable company in the world,
and start to offer that out
to every company in the world.
And for me that's,
speaking of ethics,
that's kind of where my
ethics have always leaned.
How do we build tools that
enable other people to take
care of what they care about?
MARK MANDEL: So I guess you're
the VP of Product Management.
What is a day in the life of a
VP of Product Management look
like now that you're at Google?
SAM RAMJI: Well,
it's pretty great.
First of all, I think one of
the great things about Google
is it's a bit of a
Montessori school,
so there's an
inversion of control.
The most important
person in a Montessori
is the student, not the teacher.
And I think at Google
the most important people
are the people who are
actually doing the work, not
the managers.
And that's consistent from what
I've heard from Google culture
over the last 19 years.
So it doesn't feel very
much like, oh, you know,
I'm a senior executive.
And thank goodness, because
I was born in Berkeley
and raised in
Oakland, so I'm pretty
antihierarchical and
antiauthoritarian.
So day in the life,
email, review some stuff,
get your mind blown
because Jeff Dean just
did a talk at NIPS
on how you can create
next-generation
high-performance computer
indexes via machine learning and
not classical data structures.
Deal with
prioritization-- what are
we going to ship, what
are we not going to ship?
Where do we apply the headcount?
And then what's
open-source strategy mean,
where there's a lot
of opinions on that,
but how do we start to apply
that since open source is
so meaningful to us
and it's at scale?
But should we do this or that?
And is that 10 engineers or 20?
And what's the
opportunity cost there?
And then, hey, how do we
go and talk about this?
So we got a conference schedule
coming up for this year.
What are we going to
be ready to talk about
and how can we use other
people's heartbeats
well to stay both on
message and empirical?
What have we learned
and therefore
do we want to offer you from
our learning-- not theoretical
and certainly keeping
it honest and humble.
So it's a pretty great job.
I think any job has
got its share of horses
and mucking out the stable.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's true.
SAM RAMJI: We want
find the right balance.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's very true.
SAM RAMJI: But we muck out
stables because we love horses.
So I think this
is the place where
the things that I
really care about
and the people that
I want to work with--
super nerdy people
who are like, hey, it
makes you more credible
as an executive
that you're also
a dungeon master.
I'm like--
[LAUGHTER]
Not that many companies are,
like, yeah, well, of course
you play D&D. We all do.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's
very acceptable here.
So in terms of--
it sounds very clear
to me why you've
got your background, how
you ended up definitely
involved in open source.
What do you miss
about Cloud Foundry?
SAM RAMJI: I miss the
interaction with the board.
So it's interesting to
be a CEO in a company
where you were constructing,
working with senior vice
presidents, CEOs
of other companies
who really only have an hour
a month to hang out with you.
And they know that we're
all going in the same way
and they expect you to
make all the decisions.
You've got the entire scope.
If it fails, it's your fault.
If you succeed, it's the team.
But I never had a performance
review because it was either
the company was doing
well or it wasn't, and we
needed to adjust those things.
So there was no layer of ego.
Everything was just a thing.
And so getting into a mode where
we start managing and judging
people and justifying our
existence as opposed to going,
gosh, I'm putting
every waking heartbeat
into making this great.
And we're all pretty
good at this stuff,
so let's get some
feedback on how to tune.
But do we need to do
calibrations on all this stuff?
So it's interesting to get
back into a large company
because I was at
Microsoft in the 2000s.
At that point, you know, many
tens of thousands of people.
When I left, I think it
was 90,000 employees.
So you have to have
these systems in place.
But that shift from
constantly being
in the doing to also having
to come back and assess
and sort of justify existence,
it's an emotional adjustment.
MARK MANDEL: So now I'm
actually kind of curious.
Now that you've come to Google--
and I love that metaphor
of Montessori school.
I think that's spot
on for how Google is.
SAM RAMJI: That was given to me
by a friend, so I credit him.
MARK MANDEL: That is spot on.
But I'm actually
kind of curious,
what's been the most
surprising thing for you
coming to work with Google
or Google Cloud specifically?
SAM RAMJI: God, how
nice people are.
I anticipated that a
little bit on the way in,
but I think it also
surprised me based
on my prior sense of
Google because certainly,
for example, before
this podcast,
it was very hard to understand
what Google people were
like because the
company's ethos was like,
you'll encounter us
through our web interfaces.
And we can make up
a lot of stories
like remote, hard to deal
with, superior, maybe.
And then you actually
get into these things.
One of the things I get to
do as a product manager is I
get to do product management
for Eric Brewer, the person who
authored CAP theorem.
And students in his classes
invented things like Databricks
as a side project--
amazingly cool, super humble.
You're just encountering
everybody's sort
at the first order
of experience.
You're not encountering what
they think about themselves.
You're encountering
what everybody
thinks about the problems.
And it's a wonderful
surprise, and it
catches me off guard
still every single day,
because so much of the
industry in my experience
hasn't been like that.
Don't you know who I am?
Ladies and gentlemen, this
person doesn't know who he is.
It's really nice to find people
who are just into the work
no matter what they've done
and just moving forward.
So really nice,
super smart people
with a lot of emotional
intelligence, and that's
a pleasure.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, clearly you've
had very little experience.
So I'm curious, where do you
want to go with your career?
What gets you excited
to learn about?
SAM RAMJI: Oh, two
great questions.
I think there's a great quote
from the founder of Aikido
which is a relatively
young martial art.
His name is Morihei Ueshiba.
People call Osensei.
He said, "True victory is
victory over the self."
So in terms of learning,
one of the things
that I want to continue to do
is learn, how can I be better?
There's some challenges
around, how do
you do scalable communication?
I speak from the heart,
got relatively good
values and ethics.
I can still make mistakes
in spoken language
when I'm talking
with 500 people,
and somebody's going
to get offended.
And that's harm.
And I feel bad about that.
But the feedback is like,
OK, I can do better at that.
So a lot of the
learning is just how
to take care of large groups
of people in communication
and understand, how can
I provide a little bit
of input and guidance
that will open up
something useful to them that
will generally get us moving
in a common direction?
Intense and difficult
skill, and one
that you can only learn when
you're in a position where
that's your job.
You kind of can't
do this in school.
MELANIE WARRICK: You're
at the heart of it,
always thinking of distributed
computing in some way, shape,
or form.
SAM RAMJI: But that's
the interesting thing.
It's like rather than
distributed computation,
distributed cognition
is really interesting
because we're the people
doing the cognitive work.
We're not just
doing computation.
There is emotional labor.
There's a bunch of
other things going on.
So how do we do that stuff?
That's the learning front.
I think in terms of what I want
to do, for the next decade,
I would like to help Google take
what it's reinvented in what we
now call DevOps and CICD
and next-generation static
analysis, monitoring operations,
site-reliability engineering,
this whole sort
of soup of words--
what it is is a
digital operating model
that has allowed Google to
create a great advertising
business because it can
iterate everything about it
many times a day.
I think we ship to production
about 9,000 times a day.
But again, not to get
distracted by what
does it take to ship 9,000 times
a day but why would you do it,
because you can be in this
very tight feedback loop
where you're constantly
learning from your users.
And that's true regardless
of your industry.
We're in search and ads.
Spotify's in music.
They are iterating
their environment.
I heard they ship to production
like 3,000 times a day.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow.
SAM RAMJI: So what is that
digital operating model
and how do we make that real for
the entire world, no matter how
small of a company, how
new you are to software,
how large of a company,
how sophisticated you are?
How do we take
what we've learned
and offer that as a
platform for the planet
to compute how they
might care, too?
MARK MANDEL: Are there
particular technical products
that we have or potentially may
have in the future that get you
really excited?
Anything you're particularly
passionate about right now?
SAM RAMJI: Oh, boy.
MARK MANDEL: I
mean, just pick one.
SAM RAMJI: I was
going to say, clearly
I'm not a very
passionate person.
I'm really lucky, I get to care
about all the things I'm doing.
There's a lot of really
interesting things happening
in terms of how do we take
code, which is a developer's
set of intents, and turn
it into running production
systems that developers and
operators can both collaborate
on.
There's a whole chain
of technologies there,
both first-party technologies
and third-party technologies,
third party like Spinnaker
that we've gotten into.
It's an open-source project
that was started by Netflix.
And we've gotten
really involved in it.
It's a really nice way to
do multicloud computing.
And all of these
things really need
to come back to
giving developers
control of exactly how
they want their code turned
into an artifact
like a container,
how they want to structure
it into services and pods,
and where they might
want to run it.
So I think part of what
brought me to Google
was this core belief
in open hybrid cloud.
When I left Cloud
Foundry, I had spent
two years committing
all of my heartbeats
to putting technology
back under the control
of the companies that
use it rather than
the companies that sell it.
And part of what brought
me here was Brian Stevens
said, "Our mission is
to be the open cloud."
I said, "You must be kidding me.
That doesn't make any sense.
Every hyperscale cloud
provider is clearly
an ambitious monopolist."
Not at all, right?
So when we look at this,
we say your computation
should be wherever it is.
That's a really hard
problem to solve.
How do we give you
a control plane that
lets you build your
code however you want,
deploy it however
you want, including
to multiple environments on
premises, multiple clouds,
and then keep track of
how it's all working?
So that's really
soaking up my attention
because I think so many
things are moving fast
but better understood.
Like in infrastructure service,
which we do a great job of,
we're continuing to add
things like tensor processing
units, 180 teraflops of
compute on a single board.
Just kind of mind
blowing, and that's just
the current generation.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yeah, it's fantastic.
SAM RAMJI: Our
platform as a service
work we're doing around
App Engine, serverless,
Google Kubernetes Engine,
our cloud services platform.
Those things are all
fascinating, better understood,
and moving quickly.
This slightly-- maybe we'll
use the word inchoate,
it's not completely formed--
world of, I'm a developer
and I'm writing code.
How do we make sure
the correct code that's
scalable and optimized
gets to production
and can be iterated fast by a
distributed, diverse, inclusive
team of people to make sure
that the whole thing works?
That's fascinating to me.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Do you remember,
when you were coding,
what you enjoyed the
most about writing code?
SAM RAMJI: Focus.
MARK MANDEL: Just one thing?
SAM RAMJI: Just such a
visceral pleasure, right,
just being able to sit down.
And as developers, I was
doing most of my code
in the '90s on C++.
And you're working
your brain out.
You're working 12,
14 hours a day.
And there's actually
a deep pleasure
in being able to focus your
brain for that much time.
Put on your headphones, put
the football on your computer
monitor that says
don't interrupt me
because it's neon
orange and everybody's
going to know to
leave you alone,
whatever those things are.
And there's a real satisfaction
in getting your brain so deep
in something and at the
end, compiles, runs.
It works.
It's bug free.
You've kind of done
the right design work
and everything has come through.
Or you end up with a gnarly
bug and you're like, oh,
my God, what the hell is
happening with memory?
These really interesting
intellectual problems,
you're kind of constantly
doing science on your own work.
And you're constantly learning.
So there's a lot
of things about it.
But the one thing, just focus.
If you're a happy programmer,
it's because you're focusing.
And if you're unhappy, it's
because product managers
are bothering you all the time.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's true.
MARK MANDEL: You seem quite
passionate about open source,
which common passion I think
of both of ours, and probably
very many people here
inside Google especially.
SAM RAMJI: It does seem
to be like a particularly
Google-y attribute.
There's a thing
that just whatever
you happen to be
doing, the ethics
seem to be around openness
and end-user control.
And so you look at YouTube,
broadcast yourself.
Open source is kind of
like for programmers,
like broadcast
yourself, and borrow.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
But I think it's
interesting to look
at the landscape of open source.
Like I almost think
back-- you want
to go back to the '90s
when it was shareware.
That's even pre-open source.
But how that landscape has
changed over even the last 10
years, I'm sure you have
opinions about things
like that, about how open
source has really almost become
a corporate thing in many ways.
SAM RAMJI: It's
interesting, there
was a meet up in, I
want to say, 2006,
2007 called the Open
Source Think Tank.
And there were several dozen
open source technologists,
business leaders.
And one of the sessions was a
challenge, a working session
for the whole group to
say, what do you want
the brand of open source to be?
And I ended up at a table
where one of these folks
I won't name, who was a
respected open-source CEO
at the time, he said,
"Open source should
stand for revolutionary."
And I said, I respectfully
completely disagree.
Every revolution,
if it's successful,
becomes the establishment.
So that's where we're at, right?
You play your kids Bob Dylan
and they're not like, oh man,
that's so hot and revolutionary.
They're like, oh man,
who's that old guy?
I heard that music growing up.
So open source, I think, is
at that point on the track.
It is a basic expectation,
the core licensing
model for developers.
The fascinating thing I
think that it represents
is actually the shift from
artisanal or craft level
to more industrial-scale
use of software.
If you look at what's
happened in every industry,
the very first machines built
in the Industrial Revolution
weren't using standard
fasteners or standard tools.
You look at the
construction industry,
people were using
bespoke pieces of wood.
When you get to two
by fours and you
get to eighth-inch precision
on the nails and fasteners
you're using, you start to
standardize the profession
and it actually
expands dramatically.
So I see open source as
being the standardization,
even though the standards
kind of keep moving.
You're not trying to guess what
some weird proprietary thing
is.
You're like, well,
of course we're
going to use Node.js, right?
There's a bunch of standards
you can assume that you're
going to use in any case.
And that enables us to do
more professionalization, more
industrialization.
And I think we'll probably
see, over the next couple
of decades, 10 times
more developers
than we have today, just as you
will see any industry expand
based on better common
standards, better
understanding of what
value looks like,
and a more predictable path
from, I have an idea to, I
have a result.
MELANIE WARRICK:
I'm curious, too,
if you think where
things are going if--
education has been
evolving to a degree.
Do you think that
that's going to continue
to keep shifting and
changing, especially
in the tech side of things,
especially from a computer
science-developer perspective?
SAM RAMJI: It feels
like it has to.
I think so much of our
education system now still--
and I'm not speaking out
of personal knowledge
or experience, so maybe I'm
being an internet professor.
My wife was a sixth-grade
teacher for about six years,
so I've learned a bit from her.
Much of our current
education system
is built on the
US Army's insights
in the early 1900s about
how to sort of induct
and indoctrinate and assess
tens or hundreds of thousands
of people at a time,
and then to get
them to produce predictable
results by standardizing
the process.
That seems pretty different
from the world we're in today.
So is education in that
style really helping us
deal with a world that
is changing faster?
I don't think it's just because
we're getting older that we
feel like it's going faster.
Measurably it's getting faster.
And organizations are having
a harder time adapting to it--
so a more adaptive
education system
that teaches us how to learn.
Alvin Toffler wrote
a book in the 1980s
called "Future Shock."
And there's an
outstanding quote that
has crystallized my thinking.
He says, "The illiterate of the
future will not be those who
cannot read and write.
The illiterate of the future
will be those who cannot learn
and unlearn."
So how are we
getting our society
ready for the 21st
century by teaching people
that knowledge is
actually ephemeral?
You can kind of page
it in and page it out.
It's the structure of knowing
what to know and how to know it
that are the important skills.
How are we enabling
people to do that?
Certainly programmers know this.
This is something that's
been core to our industry.
So what do we do to
make ourselves better
and what can we
learn from how we've
learned to help other
industries make that same leap?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
curious, though,
as well, that sounds like
the future education-wise,
but technologically-wise,
do you think
there are particular
challenges on the horizon?
You're talking more
about standardization
around technical models, but
there could also potentially
be diversification as
new things come up.
How do you think we're
going to kind of combat
that sort of ebb and
flow of that kind
of technological change?
SAM RAMJI: Boy, can you combat
it, or can you learn to surf?
I think so much of this is--
and I'll make another
personal reference
about a 17-year-old
Buddhist practice.
And as you kind of go
through mindfulness
and then you kind
of get into, what
are they trying to teach
you, one of the big things
is, don't cling.
It's the clinging itself,
to believe that something's
permanent and durable, that is
going to cause you suffering.
So if we can of go,
well, things are
going to be in a
constant set of change,
can we teach people how to
navigate and say, actually,
the next technology
looks like this?
What I'd like to
see that we need
to do to support
human beings in this,
whether we're a large
software vendor like Google
or if we're a tiny
company using that,
how do you build an expectation
that, as companies, we
take care of people to learn
new things and to retrain,
and that we don't expect
that everybody's at 100%
efficiency all the time?
That we say, OK,
well, we'd like you
to be at 50% efficiency for
the next three or four months
as you get ready
for a leap forward
by learning this new thing
because times have changed.
This kind of changing the
basic ethics of what business
is to continue education
in work will probably
get us into a less fractious
society where we're not
leaving people behind.
So I tend to think
of the larger scale
societal issues as
being more important
because the people who
are already in tech
are going to be fine.
MELANIE WARRICK: Is there
anything in particular
that you found that you've
clinged to in the past
that you wish you
had let go of sooner?
SAM RAMJI: Oh, that's
a wonderful question.
I think probably
ego and identity.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
was thinking tech,
but this is definitely
more profound.
SAM RAMJI: You know,
just like, it's
easy to get mad about
a thing because you're
hanging onto the idea.
And then if you take
another look behind that,
you're hanging onto the
idea because it was yours
and it means something
about you if it is right
or if it's wrong.
So I think-- you know, I've
been a strategy professional
for about 15 years.
And going from my
early days where
I was a really bad strategist--
I was really hanging
on to the ideas--
and these days where I'm
a less bad strategist,
the ideas are a little bit
like a Lego block on the table.
It's not me.
It's a Lego block.
Let's talk about the structure.
Can it be made better?
Let's attack the ideas
to improve them and not
cling to them.
So that was kind of a
big professional outcome
from letting go of ego because
it allows us to collaborate
better, because you're
not offending me
when you beat up the idea.
You're actually helping me and
we're all benefiting from it.
MARK MANDEL: Strong
opinions weakly held?
SAM RAMJI: Sure,
and scientifically.
MARK MANDEL: Actually if
you want to swing back,
like loose coupling, right?
SAM RAMJI: For sure.
MARK MANDEL: It's a
technical perspective.
SAM RAMJI: Yeah, or to
quote a terrible '80s hit,
hold on loosely.
Now you're all thinking
about Southern rock
if you share any
of my interests.
MELANIE WARRICK: If you know
any of that, that's nice.
MARK MANDEL: All right, let's
swing it back to Google Cloud.
We are the "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast,"
as much as this is wonderful.
MELANIE WARRICK: We are.
MARK MANDEL: I'm going to
throw the wonderful question.
If you had to look
into a crystal ball,
for lack of a metaphor
that's better, 5 years,
10 years in the
future, where do you
think this cloud
stuff is going to go?
What do you see in
the future that way?
SAM RAMJI: I think it's
going to become obvious
that there's no manifest
destiny for cloud computing
just because it
happens to be a cloud.
I think you'll find that
computing is everywhere.
One analogy that folks
have drawn to computing
is electricity, which is
broken in a couple of ways.
But the most important
failure of the analogy
is, oh hey, we have
electrical utilities,
so you don't need anything else.
And now that you
have cloud computing,
you don't need anything else.
And to that I say,
please go and count
the number of
generators in the world,
and talk to Honda about
their generator business.
It's darned good.
It turns out there's
lots of reasons
for computing to be everywhere.
And I don't just mean
like on your watch.
But actually just like
an electrical generator,
a lot of reasons for the
building to have a computer.
There's locality of reference.
There's data.
There's, oh, my God, you're on
a giant seismographic survey
vessel in the
middle of the ocean,
and you're collecting with
really powerful sensors
petabytes a day.
You're going to throw
that back to Norway
for processing via satellite?
Most likely not.
So we'll find lots
and lots of reasons
why computing
belongs everywhere.
And there's no manifest destiny
to pull it onto the cloud.
And I think that's critical.
The other thing that's
broken about the analogy--
and I admire Nick Carr.
The end of IT and all of that
stuff was well thought out.
I think mostly wrong
also because business
is distributed cognition.
Computing enables cognition.
It can't actually be
commoditized in the way
that electricity's
been commoditized.
You want to be able to
continue to move that boundary.
So I think as we continue to be
better humans, as we continue
to build better organizations
that think better together,
we will always find there's
something novel that we
continue to seek.
So your point about can you
really standardize or do
we have to kind of deal
with a little bit of a mess
there, I think it's
going to be messy
and we'll tend to avoid
pure commoditization
in the classic economic
sense for at least a decade.
Some of the things that will
push it in that way will be,
people are going to have
different approaches to machine
learning and automation.
Those opinions will
be strongly held.
How you should hold
and process the data
and how all that
stuff works, those
will tend to push
against commoditization.
MELANIE WARRICK: So a little
off the cloud for a second.
I'm curious, you were talking
before about letting go of ego.
I'm wondering what
you would recommend
or what are some of
the key traits you find
make you a successful leader or
make others successful leaders
that you've worked with?
SAM RAMJI: Well,
whether or not I'm
a successful leader
is always debatable.
MARK MANDEL: We think
you're all right.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: So-so.
SAM RAMJI: I do think
mindfulness meditation is
important.
If you can't let go
of thinking, it's
hard to know what you
think because you're
a little bit more like
a shaken can of soda
than a still glass of water.
That's super important
because it also
lets you kind of be
a little calm when
things are triggering.
One of the things that
comes up in leadership
is when a leader stands
up, two things happen.
One, everything that
opposes that person's point
of view come into
existence that same moment.
It's kind of a
philosophical construct
but I've found it to be true.
The other thing is, you are
the top-level exception handler
for the organization,
to use a C++ reference.
So if your day's
going well, you're
probably getting a half
a dozen escalations
that weren't part of your
originally scheduled routine.
And some of those, they
might be quite banal.
Sometimes they might
be quite fervent.
So for you to be the one who's
calm when everybody else is
excited is really important.
And it's easiest and less tiring
if you're calm on the inside
and on the outside.
You have to be calm
on the outside.
That's table stakes.
But being calm on the
inside lets you kind of get
through all of it.
So I think just
knowing how to relax,
how to take a step
back, and create
a safe space for
everybody else to use
their natural
human genius, which
is their intelligence of how to
work through problems, that's
the key thing.
Sometimes things will
descend into arguments.
But if you can just kind of
keep opening up a safe space,
people will work it out.
Everybody will feel
good at the end.
They'll be thankful.
And you'll be like, look,
you did it yourself.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
Well, so I think
that probably gets
us close to time in terms of
being able to talk with you.
But we really appreciate
you coming on the podcast.
Was there anything
else that you wanted
to share with us before we go?
SAM RAMJI: The best
time in the history
of the world to be a
software developer is now.
It's sort of becoming basic
tools and techniques for doing
almost every job over time.
I read an article that Rio
Tinto, one of the biggest
gold-mining companies
in the world,
says that the future miners
will be software developers.
And they're not
talking about bitcoin.
They're talking
about programming
the robots that will go down
underground and free humans
from mine collapses and dull,
dirty, and dangerous work.
Pharmaceutical
companies are saying
the future of pharmaceutical
discovery is programming.
So I think this is just kind
of a renaissance for people
who care about
producing good outcomes
and like to spend time
and focus and flow,
building logical expressions
of what ought to get done.
So come on in.
The water's great.
And we'll continue to try
to make it better for you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Well, thank you again.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Sam, thank you for
taking the time.
We really appreciate
you hanging out with us
and having a good chat.
SAM RAMJI: It's a privilege.
Thank you so much for having me.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks, Sam.
That was really great to talk
to you about your background
with GCP as well as hear
about just general thoughts
around leadership and
other areas of technology,
and your experience
with open source, too.
That was kind of cool actually
to hear about his background,
especially with Cloud Foundry.
So, Mark, let's talk about
the question of the week.
And as I mentioned, the
question of the week
is, I want to run a Google Cloud
Function every so many day,
week, whatever.
But I can't do cron.
How do I do that
in Cloud Functions?
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
So yeah, it's unfortunate
that we don't have cron
in Cloud Functions right now.
But there's some
nice workarounds.
There's a few different ways
I've seen people do this,
but this is the one
I like the best.
And it comes from our
friends over at Firebase,
which is quite nice.
And we'll link to the
GitHub repository in here.
But basically the
short answer is this.
It really requires two
things, so App Engine,
which has cron
capabilities, and Pub/Sub.
There is a link we will
have in the show notes that
points to the GitHub
repository, but basically we
set up, using this code, three
different Pub/Sub topics--
so one for hourly, one for
weekly, and one for daily.
You could obviously change
that to be your own things.
And then we have cron
with an App Engine that
just hits those and
pushes something
into that topic on
that regular basis.
That means then that you can
use those for any Cloud Function
that you want to run on that
period, which is quite cool.
So it's nice and extensible.
That's why I like
this one the most,
because Cloud Functions
have Pub/Sub hooks.
So you can fire off a
Cloud Function whenever
Pub/Sub, something
gets pushed into it
and you want to react to it.
And you can have
multiple Cloud Functions
reacting to the same
message, going through--
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's thermonuclear.
[LAUGHTER]
You could have
multiple ones reacting.
MARK MANDEL: You can have
multiple functions reacting
to a single Pub/Sub
topic push, seeing
their multiple subscribers.
So that's a really
nice extensible way
to kind of working around the
limitations we have right now.
But we'll have a link
in the show notes,
and that's available in GitHub.
MELANIE WARRICK: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: So I thought
I'd throw a challenge at you
this week.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, God.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: So we haven't
done this in a while,
but it's always great when we
get comments and suggestions
and feedback from our audience.
So I thought we would go through
how people can get in contact
with us from the podcast.
So I thought, why don't you ask
me the questions for how people
can get in contact with us?
MELANIE WARRICK: So Mark,
how do we get into contact
with the podcast?
MARK MANDEL: OK, so if you
want to reach out to us,
obviously the website's
at gcppodcast.com.
But if you want to send us an
email, it's hello@gcppodcast.
You can add us on
Twitter @GCPPodcast.
You'll see that each post has
both Reddit and Google+ links.
So if you want to find us on
Google+, it's +GCPPodcast.
On Reddit, it's /r/GCPPodcast.
You can reach out to us
directly on the #podcast channel
on the Google Cloud
Platform community Slack,
which you can find
at bit.ly/gcp-slack.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow, nice.
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
MELANIE WARRICK: You have
that all in your memory.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I've
done that a few times.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's pretty great.
A little bit.
All right, well, that's it, I
think, for us for this week.
Mark, you going to be
anywhere in the next--
MARK MANDEL: No, I'm still
just wrapping stuff up
and getting stuff ready
for a game developers
conference in March.
How about yourself?
You're off to London
soon, aren't you?
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yes, I'm going to be
speaking at the AI Congress and
talking about AI and enterprise
on January 30.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
And just a note
for the listeners
that we are not going to be
having two podcasts this week.
That was definitely a
unique thing for last week.
But we will definitely have
another one the following week.
So that's what we got.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Melanie, thank you
so much for joining me yet
another week on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And thank you, too,
all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]